on va laisser un peu les airs tous se
faire et on va implanter l'année
prochaine
une association entre du tournesol et du
sarrasin
ils sont trois à louer les 175 hectares
racheté par terre de liens près d'un
million cinq cent mille euros à un
agriculteur qui prenait sa retraite sans
l'association benjamin thiebaux avec ses
135 ha n'aurait pas pu s'installer car
des liens a permis justement d'acheter
ses terres et de me les relouer un loyer
modéré et depuis voilà c'est que terre
de liens n'entrant pas dans une
politique de commandes hier de
spéculations il reste sur des
un retour sur investissement à très long
terme donc ce qui me permet de conserver
des loyers correct ce qui n'aurait pas
été possible avec un radis un
investisseur lambda terre de lien s'est
créé en 2003 la fédération centre val de
loire existe depuis presque 10 ans et
fonctionne grâce à l'actionnariat
solidaire par exemple là on va aller au
salon terres naturelles d'orléans où là
on présente nos projets et les gens
peuvent prendre des parts à terre de
liens départ de 103 euros à peu près et
avec c'est par là ils peuvent déduire 18
% de leurs impôts et c'est par vont nous
permettre de rembourser les achats qu'on
a fait on a neuf actuellement neuf
acquisitions et on a dix acquisitions en
cours de deux dossiers
donc c'est vraiment une augmentation
exponentielle à bretons garder ses
terres agricoles un autre intérêt éviter
qu'elles ne tombent entre les mains des
riches propriétaires de vastes
territoires de chasse la commune elle à
l'emprise de la chasse la chasse disant
des grandes propriétés de chasse qui
l'entourent et finalement qui ne font
pas vivre la commune mais qui la font
mourir parce qu'on a plus que trois
agriculteurs sur la sur la commune qui
habite vraiment la commune
les deux autres projets concernent un
éleveur laitier qui pourra produire son
propre fourrage ainsi que de la
polyculture toujours bio